and then i'm going to record here
this is the boys we're spinning off
yeah this is the unprecedented we have
yeah we don't have the moderating uh
effect of alana so this is just gonna in
three seconds it's gonna be like
holding bloody carcasses and yelling
like the
you know opening of 2001. it feels
great because like you're like adults
having a conversation we're gonna ruin
that reputation
is anyone else's zoom do this weird
thing where it just decides to
um pause like your internet pauses
pauses and goes
is it just mine pauses pause it like
stop stop like you just
just did it like i have stupid fast
internet
don't you're being a dick now i'm like
[Laughter]
i couldn't keep it actually actually i
got really good at the last like
yeah really good it's a
you're not greg miller good but you're
you're getting there
i mean you're not like really good like
that i'm not greg miller
i can't take off my glasses that's
that's the i mean i can
[ __ ] with those things so they play it's
a solid play
i i wanted to wear glasses just for that
reason that's why one of the reasons why
i miss smoking is because
you just can you can
listen man and whenever there's some
business i was gonna say it's good
business
it's been a good business you
complimenting greg's taking his glasses
off i saw
a sales spike genuinely on the game
because of like
that 10 minutes on the podcast it's
scary really people are like fine
people like troy if troy is buying it on
this then i am in let's see
i definitely think that you could do
that you don't think you need to go like
troy buying it on it is veiled hatred
though
yeah that's what it is yeah yeah i know
but but the audience doesn't know that
austin we go away
it's true but i think if you had all
these different messengers in there that
could be really cool it could be this
great little
you know i have no idea what that looks
like troy do you want to
jump in no i think you have to
philosophically exclude me
you have to at no conspiracy
so genuinely we actually do have an
update coming out where we're adding a
new crew in december
and i'm about to shoot the fmv for that
with a new actor so we're having
different fmv actors coming in to do
each of them what you're saying
check your email austin i'm sure it's in
there
i haven't this must be an internet
outage i feel
i i won't say i feel hurt but i
definitely feel disappointed that i
wasn't a part of last week
like you guys i want to know
debate yeah i was like normally it's
like all right well troy's gonna leave
so i guess we'll just go ahead and the
rest of us can [ __ ] off
no you guys are like no we're gonna have
our longest episode
now that they're always gone it's like
well what the [ __ ]
so what did i you're stalin who's stalin
i would say that
mike is stalling austin style definitely
stalin you're
it was it was really interesting like if
you ever want to see the rorschach
effect
in reality look at the comment section
on that video because it's
people definitely like whatever
worldview you came in with you saw
like villains and heroes based on that
in the chat perfectly perfectly
interesting
actually i will have to say though to my
um
[Music]
great happiness it really no no no
actually it i was very um heartened to
see that probably 80 percent of the
reaction
was just i wish all political
discussions were like this
uh it seemed overwhelmingly that people
were just happy to see
two people or three people
um sort of just exchanging ideas and it
wasn't
instantly devolving into some well you
know
look if you see the world that way
you're just evil and i can never
communicate with you
uh kind of thing people overwhelming it
helps the world
like nice people like there was no awful
work there was no one in the room like
actually asking for like a bad political
like a mean
spirited political stance like it wasn't
there was i didn't we didn't like
you weren't you you or i wasn't like
weren't calling for something awful that
the other ones had to stand up to i
think we were all being quite reasonable
because we're all
politically probably kind of floating
around in a similar space right
we're also dealing with similar life
experiences for example so we're not
gonna
there's no there's not so much tension
there as well which is which is
interesting
yeah certainly and that may be a blind
spot uh but it also may be
a way to make it easier to discuss that
stuff but i also think
but the reality is that most people are
in reality closer to each other than
they think but because people have a
tendency to
caricature they drive a wedge
more aggressively and farther uh just by
virtue of the way they kind of
straw man each other's positions and
then very quickly you know
find themselves arguing with the
positions that the the opponent doesn't
really have
and and to be clear i i i did not see us
as really
debating it's because i didn't feel like
i was
throwing down on some proposition of
like it
is this way i i i went back and listened
to the whole thing and i
certainly think i could have said a lot
of things more clearly because my main
goal is to ask questions
and to kind of provoke uh a response
that i can then learn from and say
that that exposes some lines of thought
i hadn't
considered or or yeah i i have a bias
there
that kind of blocked data that i
wasn't aware of but yeah it's those fun
like five-hour conversations right where
you went like for me it was uni it was
like
sitting in a dorm room with someone who
just had a completely different life
experience than me
just five hours of like so explain why
you think this and like i'm but
listening you know that's the thing is
not not arguing but actually listening
like
i have a i had a really good friend in
uni who was um very religious and i'm an
atheist
so we would have these like six-hour
kind of conversations where like
we weren't trying to convert the other
one but we were definitely like
prodding and trying to investigate each
other's world views and i think i
learned a lot
from those conversations i'm still an
atheist but i learned a lot about kind
of those perspectives
i love that i'm i'm yeah that i'm
addicted to that kind of stuff i'm sure
he hated me as a result like obviously
that was the
oh man i'm sure he prays for me no he no
i think he was i mean he was a he was a
very you know strongly religious person
living in this era which is a very
different time for
someone who's got strong religious
beliefs so i think he he probably also
benefited from
my arguments and my perspective so i
think it was a really nice free flow of
i hope so yeah
which is school which is what i go
don't never argue with the welsh never
argue with the welsh well i'm half welsh
so i'm like
that's what i'm saying never argue i
will never argue with half of you
from the waist down i beseech i beseech
the actual british part of you and not
the part that's in conflict with
yourself
um i am one girl
i am i really that is podcast with um
this author donald j robertson last week
and and um
stoked to listen to that dude it's
you're stoic to listen to that
um he made it i've bounced it in the
wind
i've never i've never had an opportunity
to like finish a book and then literally
sit down with the author and talk to him
about it like that's that's like it was
a really rare
opportunity but um just just great
it was a poem i wrote a [ __ ] poem
seven what's the red dwarf joke when
they find the first page of the bible it
says the the events and characters in
this yeah
dude i'm actually i always think of that
i always think that family guy you know
where
where he's doing the like thing behind
his back where he's like
it's like turns out people were a lot
easier to uh impress back then
jesus was was actually shorter than that
okay so i'm back here
spit out the gum but in my uni years i
learned how to respect people
the reminder that um those people
exist in our lives even with if you have
total oppositional views
and there's some there's a lot of people
that posted this week on on twitter and
stuff talking about you know
um if you feel this way you were blocked
and i was like
that that's like saying if i'm gonna get
strong
i ain't going to the gym and it's like
these people exist in your life
to teach you how to be able to
argue better or by you know god forbid
that you actually learn empathy because
that is what is in the most
that is depleted to a deficient state in
this whole world right now it's just
empathy
not just not just that but you might be
wrong
there's that
that's the main thing is i if i'm right
right now with what i know
that sucks
at that point you can just chill i
thought i hope that i'm trending right
but then if i'm right if i'm like oh
i've figured it out
[ __ ] i don't want that at all i want to
be wrong about so many things i don't
want somebody else to come in and go
actually this or confirm what i think
to be right or to be true and
then i can go oh so it's that plus this
but if it's
my position that's it that's [ __ ]
especially
especially because if you are sitting
there
content and confident in how right you
are
the odds exponentially increase that
you're not yeah dude yeah it's laziness
right it's a different form of life
magellan that's like catholic church
we still got this like no pretty sure
it's round
no yeah i blocked
one of the things that we kept talking
about was the
um the the whole
almost spiritual beauty of the words i
don't know
and how the um it's a shame that we've
kind of gotten to a place and maybe this
is just human nature maybe it's it's not
that we've gotten here but it's
it's always been this way that people
there's a real shame in a real
self-consciousness with being proven
wrong
which i i've always seen the other way i
probably just
because i was raised this way but for me
the
the joy of being proven wrong comes from
the fact that
in that moment you are no longer wrong
that's why it's exciting like when you
suddenly realize
hey i was wrong it's because you've been
shown the right answer
and that's a nice way of looking at it
what could be what could be better than
that you know what i mean i i think it's
amazing
but how do you get there unless you have
those conversations unless you have
those
debates and and that will you need good
faith you need you need the other party
to come at it in good faith i mean
that's where it often goes wrong is if
you're talking to someone or
discussing or debating and you don't
feel comfortable in that conversation or
you feel
that the other person is making bad
faith arguments it's very hard to arrive
at that kind of
comfort level i guess we're very
fortunate that we like and respect each
other so
whatever we said we would the other ones
would be like
i'm gonna i'm gonna take on good faith
that like mike misspoke there and he
didn't actually mean the awful thing
or he's coming at it with a different
perspective austin's saying politicians
are sub-human
human i don't think they're human that
was one of my favorites
you doubled down
no i think i think um i think you're i
think you're right uh
though i do i do think
um like there's this
moment i remember in buffy where
willow is like possessed and xander
keeps saying to her
i love you and she hits him harder and
like
you know she's got this full demon
energy going on and she's you know
cutting him open and there's blood and
his clothes are all [ __ ] up
and he says you know willow i love you
and because she's basically like this
metaphor for an addict right she's
become addicted to magic
and um and the more he leans in
and just says i'm here for you the
harder she hits the harder he is but he
keeps taking one step closer until
eventually
she's just pounding on his chest and
collapses into a puddle of tears and
and and finally you know he reaches her
and is like i am here for you
and i always and you know yes i know
that i know it's obviously it's
it's it's it's poetic and in a way it's
the best case scenario for dealing with
someone that is fundamentally on a
different
page from you in that moment but when i
look around and i see
yes people should be approaching that in
good faith but
but the more we kind of radically
empathize with people and say
like just pause
take a breath try again
instead of just throwing down the wall
immediately and and
and and just saying well you know you're
you're an asset you're an [ __ ] who i
i just will never
relate to like i really don't think the
majority of people are not reachable
even even the most die-hard i mean have
you seen the have you seen that
that's a risk to reach them right like
it's a risk it takes it's it takes some
personal risk to reach out to those
people i spend like especially like
bad people right like there is it's a
tough thing
you've got to be in a position to do
that you know that's a risky yeah
but i would argue that the number of
people that are genuinely bad is pretty
small
now i will say in the context of this uh
conversation that we had last week
i fully acknowledge that part of the
subtext is i'm going in
knowing that you and alana and troy this
would hold true if you were there too
um hopefully is uh well that's not
that's why we wait till we go in austin
troy
i am it's okay i'm talking about
politics geez
i i do recognize that i i'm very very
eager to hear
what you guys think specifically because
i know
that you it the odds that you will have
just simply never thought of an issue
before and and but would then still feel
compelled to just spout out a bunch of
sort of off-the-cuff things is very low
like
if you challenge me i'm immediately
interested because i think
you know they've arrived at this
thoughtfully
they're they're not idiots and they're
not uncaring and they're not
you know blind to the world i i really
would genuinely love to know
the process that even if we don't end up
moving an inch and and i really and
again that portrays it as though it was
some contentious debate in my mind it
really wasn't a debate at all it's just
conversation but but even if it had been
and even if no one moved
we're still the better uh for it you
know
i think i love it i and i i i learned
and i also
you know some people sent me articles
podcasts all kinds of stuff that
that that you know i think were
resonating with what you were saying and
said hey austin you should check out
this and i've i've got them all teed up
here i can't wait to dive in well that's
cool
that's really cool and i think that's
and yeah that's that's similar for me as
well because i think
often yeah i think i think i think it
was definitely similarly though it's
things i took away from that
conversation that i'd
honestly in most of it was things i'd
not thought about like perspectives i
think we do
once we settle into a mode of thinking
we we often don't challenge that so it's
always yeah i think it's always healthy
but i think there are there's definitely
it's not the role of all political
conversations be like that i'm
definitely on the side of like no some
political conversations should be
aggressive
like some political conversations are
difficult and and the power dynamic is
such that
the voices need to be raised but that's
not what this is that's not what this
group is this that's not
what what we do here but i i wouldn't go
so far as to say that all of them should
be like that so it's i'm always very
cautious about
that saying i know that's not what you
were saying i just wanted to kind of put
that
you know what this group is though this
group is what's the script
the four of uh hey
[ __ ] intros man good timing you know
what's
funny is i just having this conversation
has taught me so much
even just this conversation in this
conversation i have learned
um that there's a button
we are semi-functional without alana
yeah there's a button
we're very self-indulgent without
aladdin we just do post game on our last
conversation
you're stepping on my joke i apologize i
discovered
that there's a button i can push um
that means uh i don't record
all of the audio and i just record mine
nice thing we are independently
recording then
yeah but that's how the magic happens
amazing incredible i love that but if
it's my audio
you're going to hear all of it so
beautiful you just said the last time
that happened
it was very popular i think
i i just want to make one last little
closing comment on the whole
sort of in good faith can you reach
people that are fundamentally on a
different wavelength of use
there's just a documentary i would love
to recommend that's called accidental
courtesy have
any of you guys heard of this nope but
i'll check it out so there's this
um there's this musician um named daryl
davis
black guy who basically went to uh
kkk rallies and just over the course of
decades befriended people
and one by one convinced many many many
of these people to get rid of their
robes
and he was like i i will win these
people over with kindness and i will be
very non-judgmental with them and we'll
just open our hearts to each other and
this is a guy
going to kkk that's right and meetings
and stuff
that's a risk right that's taking a risk
oh yeah
for him it was a hobby he was a he's a
gigging musician
uh and uh there are there are like
dozens i can't remember the number but
there's a non-trivial number of
people that that basically renounce to
the kkk and sometimes
it's after a long relationship you know
it's not like they meet him and 10
minutes later they go oh my god i've
been so blind
it's like they're like hey you're pretty
cool but you know
yeah exactly and to me he represents
it's like that's the best of us right
that is the absolute pinnacle of
of hey hi i try to get that i try this
this took me a long time so that i could
make this specific goof
hey
when i have to announce it but i was
like i need to go on google maps and i
need to find the image and i need to
make sure i bet you that image
and that company are okay i hope that
people are in that company aren't
getting like massive review bombs
[Music]
you're right on the cusp of that need
um hi everyone i'm late because i was in
a meeting that pertains to my
new job which i get to announce on
monday i officially i'm allowed to
announce it on monday so everyone
awesome what do you guys been chatting
about it's actually a landscaping
position
very exciting this new office my
first event was super weird by the way
for the four seasons landscaping company
very big for me uh what have you guys
been chatting about oh man just
all the [ __ ] that i missed last week
with uh all the political stuff from
last week
yeah mm-hmm very cool i guess i'll just
jump in here and introduce the show then
hi everyone i'm alana
that's troy that's mike oh this is
that's awesome
i even screwed it up
[Laughter]
this is fun every time this is austin
and that is mike
oh i did it bam uh i just had to i think
except that both of yours were three out
of three wrong from my perspective
from your perspective and your
perspective is wrong reported deleted
blocked that's really the choice away
if there's anything that i know about
troy is that he frequently says your
perspective is wrong deleted
blocked yes right it's really his
evidence it's kind of my brand
right it's gonna be on that it's gonna
be on the tombstone
locked clearly oh my god um so i was
gonna say
uh austin the pathless you just sent us
um some of the uh review scores and it
looks like it's doing real well but it
also comes out
comes out yeah thursday well by i guess
when this is live it will have come out
yesterday
um yeah very excited i didn't actually
know
until yesterday that the review embargo
would lift
uh today and even then i had forgotten
until i just got tagged on twitter
someone the tweet i sent you guys of
someone who had compiled a few of the
scores
just tagged me and i was like oh right
that's today
and uh so ultimately very different
approaches between you and mike then
who knew exactly what his reviews were
going up and was waiting for them
you were just kind of like got tagged on
twitter i got well i got distracted i
i was waiting for it in the back of my
head but yeah needless to say
slack my slack with the team was
uh you know not that one refreshes slack
but i'm refreshing slack
uh to uh to uh see and i know that that
games radar in particular seem to really
resonate with the game and really um
respond to it and and
and um felt and it looks like from
reading it that they
they saw what i would say giant squid
really was
trying to do you know a lot of the
things about the game where it's this
intersection between something that's
really fun and very gamey and
and and like driven by a very kind of
kinetic and
tactile sense with the archery and the
movement and the momentum of it you know
it's not a platformer but but just the
sheer
joy of like experiencing something that
gathers energy and gathers
momentum like that but at the same time
it's also very kind of
impressionistic and meditative and and
the open world is very um
deliberately
open for lack of a better way to put it
there's no map there's no real ui
uh the whole point is to explore it as
almost
one would in real life where you just
you just
walk around and explore and walk around
that's the aspect i'm intrigued by
that's the bit i want to play because i
i do feel
i think i've said this on twitter but
certainly something that's on my mind is
like
we are so close to like open world
becoming like an
indie explorable space for all of us so
like the the first few pioneers
including you guys
it's it's really interesting to me to
see indie scale teams
and mid scale teams kind of really
trying to explore that because it's a
whole
design paradigm that feels like it's
just becoming available to
our end of things which is really
exciting how so mike
um if you think well as is usually the
case with indy it's becoming easier and
cheaper to do so we're able to
that's that's ultimately what is so
there's the the big ones are the
improvements in streaming on the new
hardware means that you don't have to
half of the genius of like a gta game
under the hood technically
is just keeping the environment in front
of you rendering
all of that stuff that's on the horizon
bringing stuff in
loading assets unloading assets that's
you know that's teams of very expert
coders
as the streaming becomes easier um
basically i have to be less clever my
team has to be less clever which means
that it becomes more available to us at
a lower budget
that's the big one but i think just
design wise it feels like
the audience is understanding a breadth
of open world in a way that makes it
more accessible
so so what sorry what austin's saying in
terms of happens all the time
it happens you look exactly the same
that's why troy wears the hat is to just
allow us some visual differences
and thank god this doesn't work on
podcasts but it's useful for this but
like
nearby what you guys are doing versus
what goes to tsushima does
versus what um playing watchdogs legion
at the moment like
they're completely different games and
the way they're using open world
is diverse enough that what i'm hoping
is that that continues to
expand and it yeah just opens up more
space for for those of us at the lower
budgets to kind of do
cool things it looks like what what you
guys i mean by by no means you're a
it's not a plucky indie team as it's
like a kind of one of the larger scale
indie teams but it's still like a
massive
difference in scale between you guys and
uh and the triple a so it's exciting
it's very exciting it's
yeah the giant squid's kind of in that
middle zone i mean a lot basically most
quite a few of annapurna titles are you
know where they're made by
sizable teams but it's nothing compared
to
you know cd projekt and i'm not
belittling the achievement it's
genuinely amazing what
what's been what's been done there and
it looks like the reviews are honoring
that so that's great congratulations to
you and everyone's fantastic
well obviously i i'm owed effectively
none of
of that uh accolade but i had the blinky
blank you did the plinky plonk
you did that did it did a little a
little bit of this take all the ivories
look at that magic can i just stop i i
i want to say something that before he
just
diminishes his contribution to that game
i have listened to um
many of i wouldn't say all of because
there's
huge but like most of most of austin's
scores for games i've listened to
abzu is like you want to talk about
something deeply meditative like that's
just one you can just put on and chill
and i i could easily hear that at a spa
like it's a beautiful journey of course
is seminal
um assassin's creed i just started
playing uh
syndicate again speaking of watchdog
legions we were doing this thing where
we were racing
um because they're both one-to-one you
know oh one of them
was in old london one is in new london
that's right yeah and austin was like
hey hey why am i not a part of this i
was like
i realized the thing that makes me sound
so incredibly petty
i was like man [ __ ] it i forgot about
what happens when you're like
running at a dead sprint towards
something an assassin's creed in the
world goes
now and it just puts up this milky wall
of [ __ ] you
like god uh so anyway um
those are playing with it's you gotta
you gotta get pretty far out of the
center
i can show you exactly how far you can
get like you start off in white chapel
and then i was trying to get to and i
had opened up a lot of light and i'm
pretty familiar
you can't go to wales or you know they
they i'm annoyed my old flat is like
one block outside of what watchdog
legion
i was so annoyed i couldn't go up to my
old flat but really annoying that same
thing happened to me when l.a noire came
out i was so excited to drive to my
my current apartment at the time and it
was
you know like the edge of the map
basically went right into los feliz
where i was living and it just just died
and it drove me nuts
during l.a noir times it was like there
was a there was a movie
um i'll get back to your compliment in a
second there was a movie i can't
remember which one it was
i'm i'm deliberately trying to derail
you out of awkwardness
that was talking about we gotta go you
know over the we gotta go over the la
river into the country into burbank and
i was like
man well that was that was uh that was
the um
the ruben fleischer movie yes um i i
remember
watching that and the guy goes i always
knew i would die in burbank or whatever
yeah
what movie was that uh it's uh like
is that called um it's the one with um
fast times at richmond high um i'll tell
you oh god
damn it what is his name i can't
remember he's an oscar winner now he's
also a
[ __ ] sean penn
sean playing plays the bad guy
anyway it doesn't matter um driving me
nuts
it wasn't a huge hit but it was i
remember i remember that exact line
sticking out as well where they they
treated it like
a cross-country drive to go from l.a to
burbank
the this every time someone says that
phrase by the way all i think about is
the the terrible joke about
um the right the irishman with the
steering wheel in his pants
and someone says what is that he goes
it's driving me nuts anyway
um yeah you goddamn dad
that's a terrible joke i admitted it
gangster squad gangster squad yeah ruben
fleischer sean penn
uh terrible movie josh brolin
terrible movie after everybody
talking about it ryan gosling terrible
movie
does sound pretty bad that's great i saw
that that came up on my netflix
don't watch it it's not good you see
people say i just remember
this brooklyn but i really enjoyed
motherless brooklyn and everyone hated
that so i think maybe i just don't have
good enough taste for like period
americana
i think it's just regardless i think
it's just like if you want to watch that
go watch
like la confidential or yeah right
innumerable others that are of a similar
can we still watch it because i i love
that movie
rolo tomorrow mr spacey yeah
oh yeah um although he's weird i watched
i watched baby driver earlier which is
the same problem where it's like
oh can you watch capex does anybody
watch
here's the thing here's the thing
spacey's character in ellie noir is in a
way
he's competitive plays like he's like
yeah sorry uh
ellie conference yeah i was like he's an
ally in a while that would have been
expensive is that why the studio got
shut down well we had him in call of
duty and that you see how well that did
for that great people
he um he plays like the sleazy hollywood
guy
funny enough like can i posit my theory
sorry i'm interrupting you massively
austin i'm so sorry
i've got a theory that kevin spacey was
never a good actor and we just assumed
he was because we assumed he was a good
person
if you look at kevin yes here we go
right
because i watched i saw baby driver
earlier today i was just watching with
the commentaries really good that'd be
right
um every kevin spacey performance is
i'm a creepy uh awful untrustworthy bad
guy
not at all not at all not at all oh my
god outbreak oh my god outbreak will you
please just hold my hand
ah ah come on i'm bad this proves the
theory
i just i do think you are largely right
that he played
like shitty sleep duplicitous unpleasant
sleazy
he became almost a character of himself
once he started doing roles like that
people were like ooh
he plays a really good he's really good
at it because it came naturally to him
wonder why
exactly yeah that's kind of the thing
exactly that's what i was saying
he he's sort of he's playing liars
[Music]
i think i would have trouble watching
something space here but like obviously
everyone's danger has their intolerance
yeah human lies the danger it's easy
to demonize the devil
yes i see the horse i see the pitchfork
ah that's bad
it's what what is harder and what has
taken
such a shift in specifically this
industry being
hollywood and even in all of the
other industries where this systemic
misogyny racism everything else is he's
such a nice guy
come on it's fine and that's the problem
kevin spacey
his work ethic is second to none that
guy
is is was uh an incredible getting so
many opportunities for work at the
moment
yeah but i mean he was incredible
performer um
he there there's a story that he
um showed up late and
the director um basically taught him a
lesson
and kevin spacey could have easily said
do you know who i am
and he didn't he was like you're
absolutely right and he was never late
again
um so i i have anecdotes of that guy
being a good dude he was affable he was
funny as [ __ ] he's a hilarious person
that's the danger the danger is but he's
such a nice guy
well that's the outfit someone like that
assumes presumably right like that's
right
it's the frequency at which we we find
out about the kind of things that
someone like kevin spacey were doing and
we go
that guy no but i feel like that happens
almost every time
like it's so uncommon that you find out
that someone's a pedophile
and you're like no actually that checks
out like i don't think we ever assume
that of people so it is it is often that
the british have to accept jimmy savile
was a bit of an obvious one in
retrospect like jimmy
didn't he like defend it for years
before it came out
died before there were any complaints
about him in the public sphere i think
there were rumors in the tabloid
like no it was genuinely surprising and
then you see an image of jimmy savile
you're like
no that's like a cartoon character of a
pedophile that's why you cannot spot
that that's
so obvious in retrospect but i guess
again that's a similar thing right of
like
if you play the clown it's the same vibe
it's still you know
you can hide in plain sight it's it's
all i mean that's literally
he's a serial killer dressed as a clown
literally
yeah that all what i'm saying is that
i'm by no means
uh um defending nor am i even litigating
all of those allegations i'm just simply
saying that in the
that's how i was we began this
conversation of like it's
easy to have someone who says i am a
clear-cut
blank and you're like well there's no
argument to be had there's no debate
the danger lies in being able to go man
he's such a nice guy
and that's where the entanglement comes
and
i i do believe look
that's why i like to just go i'm [ __ ]
up man i've messed up
and i've made a mistake here and just
own it own it own it own it own it
so that there's just at least a level of
transparency
um i don't know that that works with
pedophilia no
it doesn't it doesn't go all right
i made a mistake sorry that's my bad
that's my bad
i want people to understand that i'm
flawed i want people to understand that
that
um i make mistakes but it's it's when
someone gets wrapped up
in but yeah but there's this and he does
this it's like man we should look at
roman polanski there's like a whole list
of people that we
um we still venerate um woody allen
you know because as as a playwright as
as a film director
as a writer it's just like it's weird
that he does seem immune to it it does
seem that woody allen's like
it's weird that he still gets to like be
around
that's strange yeah that's very strange
the thing that i'm curious about
i'm always interested in this is the
weirdest compliment to austin ever by
the way this is the strangest compliment
you can seem like a nice guy but then
you meet austin wintery
yeah right i love a hell of a build up
that's all i've seen
i love interweaving discussions of music
with pedophilia
and like the puddings when you listen to
the assassins creed
what's up with game spot oh by the way
pedophilia is like
here are the connections no my god
anyway i'm not digging myself out of
this hole this is the whole squarely
places and this is what happens
alana when you let me record the zoom
it's true any regrets austin go ahead
well i i was just you know the thing
that i
the only part of what you said that
pings i agree that
of all the things that a human can do
that are
just truly horrible um
it pedophilia is in a way
um it's it's almost i could see the
point that it's in a way worse than
murder
because basically somebody lives their
life with a deep scar
that in a way death would have been a
release from now i know i think it's
okay to just
place the top five and not worry about
their order
about the ranked choice voting of of uh
i think the top
five crimes we could just put in a blob
and say those are bad and not
i was reading a study about what the top
three things that mankind have no
forgiveness for
are which is obviously a generalization
but the three things that supposedly we
have a very difficult time ever
forgiving someone for console
exclusivity
console exclusivity is number one
pedophilia um
pedophilia animals incest and
cannibalism what
those are the top three if you know
someone who does that you're just like
[ __ ] up i can't be friends with i
can't be friends it's like
dude i had such a great time with dan
man
he's like you know he ate somebody in
the woods once
what it's like dude we go fishing like
every every weekend it's like yeah dude
dan
damn like you have a steve yeah that was
the guy yeah and there's never like a fo
well contextualize it for me it's never
like
what do you mean he like did he was he
alive when he there's never a follow-up
it's just like
oh what were the circumstances was he
stopping
still like even if you yeah even if you
were starving to death
and there was another human and you'd
still be like you but you ate
you ate the guy that's why the woods
connected as a result with a whole
heroic thing with their like you know
listen man
if i die i want you to eat me why
because i don't want to be the [ __ ]
that ate somebody
else
because i was basically i would
literally rather die
he's accidentally revealing a uh a
rejected meal drug
don't let me survive this oh
because then there's so many mental
questions that follow two people are
like what
what did you start with like what did
you did you attempt
bugs first or did you just go yeah was
there like did you go is there any
vegetation up there
there must be something in the world who
are waiting for the opportunity right
they're like
i don't want to do it but if it comes up
every time they go on a cruise
they're hoping that the whole thing will
evolve into like it was just you were
you were kind of like
that reminds me of that well hours i
don't know that you were starving
there was exactly there was an onion
headline
there was again
i started this whole thing started off
by me wanting to give austin a
compliment by the way i know
everybody let's roll back to it never
again yeah i do think
that's the compliment pay the
compliments no
send it to a higher player clearly
troy troy huh sorry are you going to
compliment us stage is yours
no because i don't know what we're going
to talk about next um
the compliment was this i have heard
almost you have to eat anyone i i've
definitely listened to
um austin's greatest hits um
he sent me the in
credits queue for the pathless
this is one you actually i think could
call a song if you like
it is a song yeah well we have that
that's a discussion that
people you guys may not be aware the
majority of what i write are not songs
but all pieces of music to
to the layman as it were our songs i say
cues like that's a cue
like you're doing this queue you're
doing this cue i've and i'd say themes
because
if austin could go i do prefer ditties
[Music]
please please let there be some like
weird glitch
in subtitles if somebody is trying to
watch this
just i do prefer and what was the last
episode
well troy started off by recording it
and there was audio issues of course
because troy um
[Music]
the audio guy but the the last the end
credits song
for for the pathless there's there's
been a few moments where i'm like
i don't i know this person like this is
a friend of mine
like you've heard it's not a surprise to
hear
these caliber of songs in films tv or
even games
but you don't know that person you know
nobody nobody really knows they're just
a hermit that lives up on a mountain and
occasionally just shits out amazingness
you're like i know that hermit
i know that person and like there's
there's a there's
been a few times where i feel that way
where i'm like man i
know who that like i shouldn't know who
that is it is
incredible not only just from the
caliber of of
song like it's but it's stuck in my head
for
days afterwards um so you should
absolutely finish the game too
and regardless of whatever you think of
the game which i think you need
if someone sends me a key i'm going to
check it out you know but i buy games
you buy games because you support your
friends
i mostly wish list them because i don't
think they get better i do wish
list them i do now you should wish
listen to this listing is great yeah
yeah
austin how long is it the game um yeah
the the it's funny because i had a hard
time gauging that
since it's pretty flexible obviously
between how much you explore and how
much you just try to kind of
follow the the the narrative beats it
looked like
one of the reviews made a passing
reference to them
needing about seven hours i think that's
probably a pretty fair
meeting love to see it it's not it's not
it sounds like
it's not shallowly yeah
it doesn't gloss past to your point mike
earlier about the the sort of
attainability of open world
that was a really cool thing to watch
during development because
the game if you walk from one corner of
the map to the other
um it would take you a good long while
you know it is
it is a not a small open world i mean
there are
you know like assassin's creed odyssey
was
noteworthy gigantic in its in its open
world it's not that size obviously
but um uh i'm just thinking that's such
a good headline in the conversation we
were having about like open world games
getting more accessible and then we
derailed it i was like that would have
been beautiful but [ __ ] here we are
sorry
yeah um no but i think um
one thing that was so cool was that they
designed the tech
where they basically were able to make a
first draft of the world procedurally
where they essentially just built this
framework where they could hit a button
and then bam
our island is is made and then often how
will triple a do it as well i think
people don't realize how much procedural
generation
in an assassin's creed or a game like
that like it's pretty oh
i'm sorry i'm not trying to d-roll come
back to the house it was making another
point no
well no no i i mean no i i want to hear
more how was your procedural generation
in
assassin's creed i would think you can't
in assassin's creed right
so so not so i think the the big
the big thing with procedure generation
is people equate procedural generation
with randomization and with uh
user facing procedure generation so like
i think asset creation or
content creation like if something's
procedurally generated
my actions equal content or assets
in the game right so exactly you think
it's reactive to you but actually
procedural generation doesn't
necessarily mean that it can just mean
basically anything where you let the
computer do some placement for you
so for example you probably would
procedurally generate anything you would
climb on in an assassin's creed game
well you'd start so you so what they
often do with open world and i mean this
is i think this has been the case
forever with ubisoft it's um tsushima is
like
very massively procedurally generated in
a way that i find incredibly instructive
and interesting
um but like how what try say your faces
okay so
so i think one it's a terminology thing
there's a way procedural generation has
been communicated to consumers which is
no man's sky roguelikes kind of infinite
comments
right but all procedural generation
means is
the computer kind of does the leg work
for you so for example every time you've
seen a blade of grass in a video game
the the design you know the level design
didn't go in and just place everything
some grass what they said was this area
should have grass in it and then the
computer
jumps in that is a very stupid low-level
version procedural generation
and then when i interact with it then
the world responds to me and says no
we're going to generate at a higher lod
right
or lof what is it called well that's
where it gets interesting with something
like ghost of tsushima because that
world is so
largely forest driven that's why one of
the reasons the loading times are so
good in goes to sashimi is it's not
it doesn't load with with procedural
generation you don't have to load
1000 blades of grass you have to load
one blade of grass
and the algorithm that decides how grass
is placed and you can generate a runtime
you
you don't have to ship the cupcake you
have to ship the recipe for the cupcake
and the ingredients which is easier so
it's that it's
it's it's the computer does a lot of the
building at run time now
what's with open worlds and this varies
from team to team so maybe my examples
will be wrong but like something like
assassin's creed
you can start by doing what austin's
describing where you basically go
we're going to generate a city and it
will just be big grey cubes and it won't
look very nice
but that lets the designers start
building stuff working out how tall
buildings should be how nice the jump
should feel how
how close together things lets you play
in that space and then once that's done
that procedurally generated city can
then be handed to your 300 artists to
make it look gorgeous
but it's you you we as developers we
constantly use procedural generation
in the process every time you see a
particle effect it's not like they've
animated
individual sprites in that particular
thing the computer does a lot of the
heavy lifting and then yes what hosting
is saying makes sense
where i see really interesting progress
in the future and i think ghost of
tsushima kind of points the way
is more more allowing more of the design
process to be handled by procedure
generation which again frees up time
which means your team can be smaller if
you look at ghost of sashima's
development team
watch those end credits again it is not
an enormous number of people similar
with horizon zero i think they're the
the smaller of all of the studios i
think for sure
this is going back to you know that's
not cheating that's a really clever way
of making games and that's and
the audience doesn't seem to mind but
you obviously get different things out
of the ghost of tsushima than you do
from uh
a watchdogs which is a very good yeah
but like one of my favorite open worlds
ever
like that goes through i loved it
beautiful ending was so good hold on
i finished it yeah
the the the co-op i i will also say
because oh my god the multiplayer is so
cool
okay okay
the thing that um i i feel this is a
moment for me and then austin
i know you want to comment on this but
the the the thing that i want to um
point out because i'll i want to know
you have like five minutes um
this is one of those moments where i
want i'm glad that i'm wrong like we
were talking about the very very
beginning
the notion that now that i know that i'm
wrong i have the opportunity to be
more right because i wasn't like fully
wrong i was trending towards
right but being able to have a
conversation go wait a minute you and i
disagree on something
i think procedurally generated is this
you're like let me actually show you how
you're not wrong but there's also right
plus
and and i'm going to show you what right
plus is now i learned more about things
where developer terms are different to
consumer terms right like
buzz yeah have been used for an audience
but it's used differently internally
but it's more important to me to have a
conversation if i'm talking to a
developer
and be able to say hey listen man i
understand that what we really want to
do is have more procedurally generated
content for them to go
that's not really what that word means
but okay now i know where you're at
i want to be able to go yeah it's like a
genre kind of so
right i want to be able to have a better
more informed conversation
i'm not being elitist here like both
readings are valid
it's just that you can yeah by
understanding the different uses in
different places you can as you say
arrive at more interesting outcomes
but it's not that you're wrong it's just
there's right plus
multiple right yeah that's right plus i
have i have uh
for years um tried to disentangle
proceed because procedural generation in
music is also a thing
and there is very often
that term is used as a placeholder for
interactive music because they basically
think
anything that's broken down into a bunch
of little tiny bite-sized granular bits
is now procedural and i'm like but these
are all still bespoke
you know fragments of audio all we're
doing is shipping the instruction manual
for how to reassemble it and take it
apart again like my
my very first ever score was flow that's
a score that's consisting of like
thousands of individual
pieces of audio that are being stitched
together as the player just kind of
drifts through the gameplay
but i never thought of it as procedural
because then i looked at actual
procedural content
uh procedural generation where you know
there's like
basically the equivalent of a hardware
synth
baked into the programming of it where
it is
literally authoring music
in real time that's procedural but yeah
and to be clear
well my point is both are like
procedural is i've read a really good
book on the subject
by uh tanya short and the or sorry by
several people
but she was one of the editors and in
the intro i think they referred to it as
procedural generation is like
simultaneously the most stupid but the
most
talented intern you could hire it's a
helper like it can be
it can do no man's sky but it can also
just kind of grab your coffee you know
what i mean
have you seen your level of engagement
and both are valid uses
have you seen procedurally generated
youtube videos
some of them is this the kind of
children's where they'll have like
weird stuff some of them yeah yeah it's
like they basically people are using
bots to make these kids videos under the
understanding of kids like loud noises
and they like cartoon characters they
can recognize and then they just
let a bot make the video meaning it is
maybe procedurally generated isn't even
the right word for that but
then they upload it gets billions of
views but when you watch it you're like
what does this do to our kids they're
like clockwork orange bizarre
like just like displays of noises and
characters that don't make any sense
whatsoever and have
billions of views on children's channels
it's so it's amazing this is a
procedurally generated youtube video
the fact that the yellow borders
surrounding the speaker that is the
computer is choosing that
alana well now troy of course the new
director of the show
isn't placing where that yellow
rectangle is um but also just in terms
of the compression the computer isn't
austin's webcam isn't bothering to send
the shape of those squares behind those
diamonds on his wall every time because
they're staying static
so the computer is reconstructing those
so there is procedural generation
arguably in everything you're right
that's a very front forward procedural
generation but
the second troy says something and the
yellow rectangle goes to him this is
procedurally generated content to some
degree
we have a a a [ __ ] intern who is moving
the yellow rectangle around and there
and game development is about knowing
where you think they're doing fine
i think he's doing a great job the
yellow square intern yeah dude i just
want to i just want to
clarify that the that the pathless is
definitely not
in the no man's sky sense of procedural
and open world it is very much a bespoke
crafted thing what they did is they used
this very
clever technique of basically letting
the computer make the first pass
and then went in placing just an ungodly
number of individual little things but
it was but to make the eye they had more
time to do that right
all the time players have to realize
this that's not
that that team's not being lazy by using
procedural generation for some of the
steps
it's freeing up its time so that they
can i've mentioned on the podcast before
my very first job in the industry that i
used to have to spend
you know 75 of my working day on is now
a button in unity
like my first job is now procedurally
generated
i made nav meshes uh which it doesn't
matter what they are but they
now button in unity that means that
anyone entering the industry now
gets to do much more interesting [ __ ]
than i did when i first started and i
think
yeah i don't that's the big thing this
is these are time savers they're not
laziness
they are about giving you more time to
do the good stuff yeah that's the thing
i don't think the game would have been
possible if they'd had to make every
detail of the island from scratch
the team's not large enough the budget
wasn't but they they were able to
short-circuit the super labor intensive
tedious part
and focus on the artistry go troy very
quickly because i know a lot of needs to
go
um just mike i have a question for you
do would you say that there's a
difference like there's a
procedurally generated may be a misnomer
when actually what people mean is
emergent like there's a difference
between emergent content
versus procedurally generated content
like if i go and i create
a new game mode out of gta because i'm
trying to break the game
or i can do this thing that's not
procedurally generated content that is
emergent gameplay is that more accurate
or user-generated yes yeah there's
there's different there's i mean i've
i've heard like five or six different
nomenclatures which will be in the
comments but like yeah there's there's
definitely like
player facing uh procedural generation
and like development tool procedure
generation but there's also as you say
like user generation
at what point does the person who's made
that gta mode that's just about breaking
gta
at what point are we actually doing them
a disservice by giving the procedural
generation credit
they've gone and done something they've
made something transformative they've
they've created something new there
so it's all very messy and hazy and
interesting and exciting i'm glad
i learned something today yeah i did
very good i learned that i should
probably not be in charge of you
recording video you watched and you
listened i did
i played i watched that listen i go i
just wanted to ask did everyone see the
bit of the video where troy plays piano
beautifully but none of us could hear it
because it's
so great oh my god yeah i found that so
funny none of us heard it so we didn't
react to it and then i heard it in the
audio and i was like this is incredible
and uh can he play us out now can we
give him that moment
with us sitting here if we can hear him
enjoying him
oh that's amazing oh there's no i can't
hear it that's awesome
i heard a sound
[Music]
it's no sense that we couldn't hear this
before
[Music]
now austin joined him
i'm serious too much power mike bethel
it's too much power
[Music]
that was nice
[Applause]
and a [ __ ] intern
i think he's doing a great job